today's topic hey what's up guys justin
wayne here
this is justin wayne one of the most
popular so-called seduction artists on
youtube
his videos have scored millions of views
and his channel has 127
000 subscribers wayne tries to prove
that his tips work by posting what he
calls in-field videos or
lay reports
is he posting photos of himself making
out the girl's bedroom
hidden camera footage of him picking up
seemingly unsuspecting women
i don't want to watch this anymore
that's gross bro
listen i'm gonna say this about it okay
there's a lot of goobers in this pickup
artist industry and so a lot of guys who
are
not only fake but very creepy and uh
yeah posting videos of you smashing prop
people even if it's censored like
i don't know if they're not consenting
especially like
bro wayne sometimes partially masks the
identity of the women in his videos
suggesting that they did not consent to
be filmed wayne claims he gets
permission for the videos that he posts
online
but he didn't blur their faces because
of any enforced standards from youtube
we've added additional blurring to
protect their identities
wayne isn't the only questionable
character who operates with impunity on
the site
he's just the one who invited us to
watch how he does it so thanks for
coming out
this is going to be a very very simple
talk it's really just about helping you
guys out where you guys are right now i
don't want to go into too much
like random theory i want to hit the
juggler most of the time you're just not
probably trying to touch the girls early
enough
that's number one and by not touching
her or trying to touch her
it's easier to get friend zone at that
point
[Music]
okay i don't know if it's the editing i
highly doubt he just started the seminar
with touching her
and like starting you know a bit of kino
or whatever
but even if he doesn't even if he
doesn't
oh it's cringe all right i'ma say this
there's a certain energy you exude when
you're really comfortable with yourself
and you're good with ladies all right
and what i've noticed watching a couple
of dudes from the
the pickup artist community or even the
red pill generally
is that some of them uh basically fake
the funk when i'm
seeing them i'm like um you're not
really about this life
and when i look at this dude i'm getting
that exact same
idea wayne's weekend boot camps cost 999
dollars
he brought along a russian woman named
jenny she also appears in wayne's
youtube videos
initially as one of his targets but now
he claims she's one of his girlfriends
proof that his methods work you know you
wanted to be touchy feely right away
in the right way and we have something
called the orders of touch okay
i'm gonna borrow you okay just come here
right
so the order to touch is basically look
you can start with for example like
high fives hand stuff that you can go
here
right the elbow this way he's trying so
hard not to laugh
but yeah let's just keep watching then
you can go
shoulder and at this point is when you
can probably go closer
then you can do like clubby nose to nose
mouth and mouth
boobs and it goes down right in general
what do you want in the end
this is what happens when people just
read stuff and then start regurgitating
this shit's weird bro
yeah i read i read a book like that and
a couple of
a couple of years ago there's a lot of
this some things that i took from that
book was a lot of things i threw away
like the bible like i'm not doing that
for me i kind of
just want to be able to to meet like the
girls that i'm attracted to you know
what i mean
you know kind of like what you have
going from what i've seen yet
but are you teaching him to be [ __ ]
oh no
definitely not i'm not saying i haven't
used any [ __ ] tactics yet with them
um teach them how to be men are you
teaching them me how to be [ __ ] no
no definitely not i haven't been
teaching them how to be [ __ ] yet
oh yeah
he said yet as if he's going to teach
them how to be [ __ ] later
everything about this dude screams fraud
the real victims and all this are the
guys who paid a grand i'm gonna say that
much
and you tell guys when a girl says no to
respect that
of course i mean actually that's why we
have you know these programs we teach
them how to gauge the levels of touch
it's not even
it's not about them getting like a
getting in trouble in court it's just
about them getting the girl
like if he overdoes it and the girl
wasn't comfortable it you know it lowers
his chances it's all about paying
attention to where she is
and that's been very successful myself
and for a lot of my students
have you guys ever game in the beach
before you're gonna have to start making
moves okay so there are some girls over
there but they're looking at us
you know what i'm saying no no what i
want you guys to do now make it easier
for me
look around for for like maybe two girls
or something
or one girl laying down see that woman
standing next to him
that's another one of wayne's supposed
girlfriends introduced to us as kelly
from finland
before leaving for the beach we'd put a
mic on wayne and we're rolling when he
got into an argument with kelly
he threatened not to pay her if she did
not cooperate
underneath one kind of apparent
exploitation we found another
let's just get this [ __ ] over because
i'm only here for the money i'm not
going to want to pay if it's like
if you embarrass me on camera i can do
anything i want
i get to remember i'm always going to
have more weapons and stuff like that
okay
just don't [ __ ] with me please okay i'm
going to lose it all i'm crazy like that
i've always been crazy that's why i put
doors online and they put years and no
one does anything to me this to me if
you don't trust me listen to this doing
this
and everything don't necessarily this to
me
yeah i expected i'm surprised
what you said you called it ain't got
nothing else to say
i didn't expect it to be flagrant though
this is weird that dude clearly
clearly threatened her i've got more
weapons i'm willing to risk it all i'm
crazy like that
that's why i posted girls online and
[ __ ] like that what and no one has done
anything to me
today's video is sponsored by surf shark
vpn
so vpn is basically an application or
web extension
that you could use on your web browser
or on your internet to
mask your ip address basically hiding
your location
from whatever website you're interacting
with now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you
based off of your ip address and so if
you're trying to view
online content the let's download
certain things based off where you live
those things could be restricted now i
like watching tv shows
feel me sometimes they're foreign feel
me and
when that happens basically i use a vpn
to be able to bypass that so i can watch
what i want to watch because i feel like
the internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers
you deserve to go wherever you'd like to
go like i said just because you see a
dude with a lot of girls
does not mean that this man knows what
he's doing
or that you should take his advice all
right i've had people approach me abba
can you give me coaching i'm not a coach
just because i've had some measure of
success in my life with my dating
prospects
does not mean i'm fit to go and teach
you how to be able to do
that's not what that means okay a lot of
these guys will come in
and just repeat what they read in books
or saw from other people
even though they haven't done any of the
work and then they'll teach it to you
and look there's plenty of seduction
coaches online that are perfectly fine
right shan budram's a good example right
she teaches he helps ladies with stuff
and stuff like that
and there's other people on the male
side who are also fine but you got dudes
like this who
no that's a no and how do you make a
difference um that's tough
that's tough because you see these guys
and they pay for women
right so the marker is a success that
you would normally see they're paying
for them he's paying for ladies to show
up
it's just a magician that has a
assistant she's in on the tricks
she's you can't rely on her she's like
oh my god what i'm doing here oh what
a brand new dress oh [ __ ] it's paid
right but then there are some
illusionists who don't necessarily
hire random people to do what they need
to do but they actually do really proper
illusions
right they don't fake their interactions
with the people there
so it's hard to know which one's which
and so i have no easy answers for you
i have no easy answers i'm not gonna lie
but i would tell you that there's a lot
of them
fake it there's a lot of people who pay
for people to come around them
yeah that's pretty much what i would
tell you after this wayne insisted
we interview her are you justin in a
relationship
yes how are you gonna ask to interview
her and you're standing behind her like
yeah go ahead and answer it
i got i gotta take you
seriously how long four years oh okay
and do you have a tattoo yeah what is it
mate he's like his name why'd you get
his name tattooed i love him
oh okay
this is one of the few times where
people i want if you guys thought that
was sus
i want you to get in the comments and be
like isis blink twice if you need help
this is those times this is one of those
times
where that's very legitimate yeah i want
you guys to also comment on a scale of
one to ten how creeped
are you by this whole thing wayne
scolded kelly for her performance
afterward
we've repeatedly tried to talk to kelly
alone but she refused
or wayne intervened do you get their
permission
to put them online yeah of course i mean
yeah a lot of times
i'm just like jenny for example she i
told her and she was like okay and
they don't like if they don't want to i
just not show anything you know simple
she said the video was up for a month
before you told her about it
no she knew that the video would post
she just didn't ask me
like when it was posted so that's a
clarification that's not what she told
me
and so is everything that happens in the
video real
yes did you pay jenny or kelly
no did you pay them to be on camera
while we were here
no you didn't pay either of them nope
she would
do it for me because i'm good to her as
a you know as a boyfriend
i heard you say that you wouldn't pay
her if she didn't do the interview and
make you look good
oh yeah i told you the interview well it
was i'm not going to be the airport in
general
not pay her that's not what him that's
not what you threaten her
basically i'm just like yo you know come
on you can do this you know she's like i
know i'm scared like
come on don't do this you make me upset
you know i was like upset because she
seemed
and she also seemed upset about the
campaign i don't know if anybody want to
do this you know like you know i've done
a lot for you
i noticed that like a lot of the girls
in your videos are foreign why is that
so you know there's american girls also
but a lot of them are foreign because
you know new york and uh miami is a lot
of foreign girls
hold up coincidence yeah can i get some
water you know this is not like
you know something that oh this just
that you guys know
excuse me uh-huh i prefer just to talk
to you about like my teachings yeah i
don't want to create anything where it's
like
too much about like fishness about me
like really mistreating people
four days after our interview wayne took
down all his youtube videos
a day later he released this cryptic
message announcing his retirement
kind of for now i'm just kind of like
relaxing
you know sometimes everyone needs a
break but less than a week after that
he put a few of the old videos back
online we asked youtube if the sorts of
videos that wayne and others post
violate the platform's terms of service
we also asked if the site ran ads on
them
and what mechanisms youtube has in place
to prevent such content from existing on
the site in the first place
in response a youtube spokesperson
provided a short statement about their
privacy complaint process
[Music]
even if justin wayne ends up quitting
the internet there will be plenty of
other pickup artists to take his place
as well as creators of every other shade
of questionable disturbing or
potentially illegal content
and for now youtube will be there to
take a cut that's the beautiful thing
about this
stuff it's just such a you know elegant
work of art it's a beautiful science
art everything in one
god damn it's hard to watch
i mean it's more than hard to watch if
he did film them without their consent
then yeah that's illegal
and uh that's criminal one but two
this stuff was online you run ads on
them
i mean listen youtube counts on the
creator to say that they got the prior
right
to all those videos and so it's not on
youtube to do that if there's a privacy
concern someone's privacy was violated
the person can file and
that's youtube can't guarantee that
everyone in your videos is there and
wants to be there that's not how it
works
yeah so i can't hold youtube accountable
for that but yeah i mean if that's what
he did then that's a criminal
especially like filming them like if you
didn't if you didn't get consent for
that stuff that's creepy bro [ __ ]
that's that's crazy yeah that's crazy
i don't know it's tough people try to
pay for a lot of this coaching stuff and
oftentimes i don't know how i feel about
it always uh because again a lot of
these teachers are fake
it's not a regulated industry right so
you get a lot of snake oil salesman's
who will just
repeat what other people said just to be
able to take your money so just be
careful when you guys are out there and
seeking out that advice
and you're paying for it right just be
mindful of that
yeah i've had girls hit me up and like
man dude could you couch me i'm like
coach you like
what made you think i was a professional
coach you were wet
i don't know one girl's like matthew
hussey's a fake i need your help about
pay you like
it was pretty good money too i wasn't
gonna lie part of me wanted to take the
money just so i could be like
have you learned your lesson now you
know but um
but you know like yeah see yeah
nothing yeah yeah yeah i know you've
heard about nigerian princes
what about ethiopian princess what's up
girl
and she'd be like what about them
yeah it's just you know be careful out
there and yeah don't don't take a lot of
this advice
don't do it for the people that are
watching and they're wondering
oftentimes it's really just common sense
okay
the advice that it is is common sense
better yourself
how do i build confidence better
yourself know your worth work on
yourself
go to the gym wash yourself okay
yourself learn some [ __ ] read a book
read a book go to the gym wash yourself
learn skills learn how to cook learn how
to dance
know your worth that's what it is by
knowing your words having add some
skills
learn a new language something to talk
about some people they don't have
nothing to talk about and that's mostly
that
i'm 18 and i don't know i've been
failing and dating well that's because
you're 18 and you know you
don't learn a new skill have something
to talk about to show for that's what it
is
better yourself and know your worth
that's what i would say
other than that the rest is just extra
but
really at the base of things that's what
it is
so i'll probably tell you guys two
things one uh just seek out a lot of
adversity
i think uh as a man especially you guys
have to build character
all right and seeking out adversity
means doing things that are difficult
all right
what a lot of what preach that that
applies but also that also means
talking to ladies all right even when
it's three girls in front of you want to
go up
seek that adversity out you know as you
get more comfortable in those
environments you do it more often
the second thing is you need to reflect
it's not enough to just go bang your
head against the wall
if you're not getting able to get
through because it's concrete maybe find
some different solutions to your problem
you have to reflect on whatever failures
you have and see how you can get better
at it so
put in the work put in the effort and
then the second thing is reflect if you
don't learn from whatever mistakes that
you make
or if you don't try things differently
uh then you're not gonna have any
measure of success in that regards
so that's what it really comes down to
that's probably the two most basic
advices i could give you guys
but most people fail at number one they
don't even show up or they're too afraid
to even do the approaching
that's really that's really that i i i
suck i suck
at dating what have you done nothing i
mean
you know also at the same time in this
day and age a lot of people are like
i don't want to approach you know i'm
too afraid and i get that too
even though it partially feels like an
excuse i do understand it to some degree
there's no easy solutions guys
you gotta do it there's no easy
solutions
all right that's it for today's video
let us know what you guys think
[Music]
oh
you